Hello everyone
and welcome to
today's webinar Advances in
WBC Differential Analysis
Technology I'm Cristian Leiva from Abbott
Hematology and I'll be your moderator
for today's event Today's educational
webinar is hosted by
Bruce and brought to you  thanks to the
diagnostic voice for more
information you can visit www punto de
laboratory punto a voice is hematology
before we start i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by sending as many
questions as you want and at any time
you want during  the presentation
for this simply write your
query in the ask space and
click send we will answer as many
questions as time allows us at the
end of the presentation if you have
problems viewing or listening to the
presentation click on the
support tab located  at the
top right of the
presentation or report window of your p  problem
by clicking on the access request a
question located on the far left
of the screen
this presentation is educational and
therefore offers continuing education credits
please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right of the
window  presentation and the process
for obtaining your credits
now i will introduce our
speaker for today dr
donald white he was until recently with
abbott hematology
where he can
global scientific affairs manager donald has worked
in clinical laboratory services and in
the commercial hematology industry  hematology
throughout his career he has held
various roles including supervision of
automated hematology
educational coordination scientific marketing scientific liaison
German cell analysis and flow cytometry specialist of
various management positions
for a full bio
on our presenter visit the
pes  biography tab at the
top of your screen it is important to
mention that this virtual seminar is
a repetition translated into Spanish of
the original version broadcast by this
same medium a few months ago now
we are starting the presentation
thanks for the presentation I would like
to welcome you to the seminar
today's virtual conference on advances in
leukocyte differential technology
this conference program is
sponsored by and on behalf of abbott
diagnostics and the content of this
presentation is consistent with
all applicable fd app requirements
technological developments in
hematology analyzers  Automated
analyzers continue to transform the hematology laboratory Each new generation collects more information about the properties of blood cells than the previous generation Hematology analyzers are
available from several manufacturers,
each using a different combination
of detection methods.  ion today we will cover the
following objectives firstly i will
share with you a brief
review of the relevant milestones in the
history of automation
related to white blood cell
count and its differential then
we will see an overview of the
methodologies used in automated white blood cell counting
white blood cell and
differential counting and how these
methods are applied on current hematology analyzers will
also discuss the impact of
performing manual differential in the
laboratory and the improvements achieved in
minimizing interfering substances as
well as identification of
abnormal cells and  the alerts they generate and
lastly I will discuss some
key trends in automated differential analysis
to begin I would like to share with
you a brief history of
automated systems that contributed
to the development of
automated white blood cell analysis systems
and their difference.  Initially
prior to the 1950s
white blood cell counts were generally
performed manually using the emo
cytometer and microscopic differential counting
of 100 cells was carried
out using variations
of romanovsky stresses such as raid 15 and
mails great what's a major milestone was
the  grant of a patent to wallace
scooter for using an electronic method of
counting particles shortly after he
introduced the first
electronic viable cell counter
the colter model and with the introduction
of transistors
later models of
cell counters were developed such as the fn model and the model
s
the model that was the first
automated analyzer to provide a
7-parameter complete blood count
replacing illusions and
manual counts reduced differential reporting time
to one minute when it
normally took the lab 15
minutes in the early 1970s
technique a  instrument introduced the
twin d  e a 5-part differential analyzer
based on chemical site staining
of its white blood cell populations
analyzed with a
continuous flow optical measurement system
Various manufacturers have adopted
different technical approaches that can
produce 3, 5,
and 6-part differential results the need to reduce
A number of manual differentials
continued to drive the development of the
automated differential so
improvements were made to develop
computer-based automated digital morphology analyzers.
These systems used
primitive software to characterize images
of blood cells from a Wright-
stained smear and provided a
estimation of each cell classification
providing images for the technologist to
confirm by reviewing the computer screen
the gemma truck model 590 was one of
those early systems
in the 1980's a 6
part differential was fully incorporated into a
complete blood count analyzer by
technician which also incorporated a
laser for the detection of
scattered light the a woods the de y n 4000
appears in 1996 with the ability to
automate the counting of
nucleated red blood cells by automating
reticulocyte counts and
later introduced
automated assays  of
monoclonal antibodies to the
61 ce immune platelet count as well as
lymphocyte subsets over the
last 20 years there have been continuous
technological improvements whereby new
methods provide an even more
reliable means of reporting
automated differentials thus the goal of developing an
automated differential  of
white blood cells is to design
detection technologies to improve
accuracy in automatically
reportable blood cell subpopulations
which should decrease the
need for
manual differentials across many generations of
analyzers  Automated hematology
clinics have developed a
variety of technologies and
method combinations with each new generation of
analyzers
on this slide the methodologies
represent the technologies used
in cell counting and the
applications indicate how these
technologies combine to produce the
WBC differential now
I will review several technologies
commonly used in automated differential analysis
of blood cells
beginning with
impedance conductivity technology or
radio frequency rf optical
light scattering site chemistry and the use
of fluorescence detection
after a review of methods to
provide an overview of how
These technologies are incorporated into
multi-channel or single-channel applications.
The impedance method is based on the
measurement of the changes in direct
electric current that are produced
by a cell suspended in an
electrolytic solution as it p
through a very small opening of
known dimensions a
positive and a negative electrode are immersed on
either side of the opening to create
an electrical pathway
as each cell passes
through the opening a change
in resistance occurs between the  electrodes
because blood cells are poor
conductors of electricity this change
produces a measurable electrical pulse
which can then be used to estimate
the number and size of particles
passing through the opening the challenge
for this method in the early years
was handling coincidental events
Due to the closeness of the cells
as they pass through the aperture and
due to the recirculation of cells
around the sensing area of ​​the
aperture affecting
counting, impedance technology continues to
evolve with changes in the
reagents used.
eventually delivering a
three part WBC differential
on this day  positive we observe a
blood sample treated with an
issys reagent the
erythrocyte issys reagent impermeable the
membrane of the leukocytes causing
the membrane to collapse around the
nuclear and cytoplasmic components
of the cell the leukocytes can
then be separated using impedance
in three  general groups based on
cell size from
smallest to largest in three groups
lymphocytes medium-sized cells and
granulocytes abnormal cells
may appear as
transient populations that overlap the
three normal populations such as
nucleated red blood cells or
aggregated platelets platelets  giant or
erythrocytes analyzed to name a
few when abnormal cells are detected
they must be resolved with an
alternative method such as
microscopic slide review or
manual 100 cell
differential another key patent obtained around 1970
was the discovery of a signal of
a  high frequency using
alternating current which was defined as
radiofrequency opacity or conductivity
a high frequency alternating current signal
could demonstrate different
properties of the
white blood cell subpopulation measurement of
leukocytes by opacity result in
changes in response to nuclear composition
cytoplasmic density  and
other internal structures of leukocytes
in this case of electrical detection the
cell wall of blood cells
acts as an
alternating current conductor signal changes are not
limited to event and size
radiofrequency measurements are still used
in some hematology systems  Today
one of the difficulties associated with
measuring cells as we saw with the
impedance transducer is
actually controlling that leukocytes and other
cells do irregular recirculation
around the aperture detection zone.
This interference and
signal duplication could  r the same
cell required correction and it was found
that it could be corrected
for impedance this could be
resolved by examining the
resulting pulses and applying
pulse editing circuitry trying to
troubleshoot duplicate signals
however for optical detection it
was necessary to develop  a
new approach in a flow cytometer
the cell suspension is pumped
from the sample container into a sample tube
in a special flow chamber
called a flow cell with a small
opening at the tip
the suspension is then injected into a
stream of  fast moving with
cell free fluid called
the envelope fluid actually produces
laminar flow and this works
exactly like a laminar flow system does
now the two fluids travel at
different speeds they don't
intermingle that's what is called
laminar flow  the special geometry of
the flow cell and the slow velocity
of the liquid  enveloping causes these
cells to actually line up in a
single line looking at the animated graph to
the right you can see the cells
intersecting the
laser path in a single line the cells
are actually following the point of
least resistance and since there is  two
converging velocities seek that
easier path that's why they line up
in single file so this whole
process seen here is called
hydrodynamic focusing and all systems that
incorporate any type of
optical subsystem for detection methods
use some form of focusing
Hydrodynamics
The hydrodynamics approach was not really
limited to measuring optical light scattering
and was often incorporated into
impedance technology as well
to further improve the accuracy of that
measurement
in this figure as can be seen
as the cells and
sample streams pass create is the
linear flow of one cell at a time
these graphs show us e  Using the
hydrodynamic approach and the principles
of optical light scattering detection
the focused flow stream of the
diluted leukocytes is injected into the
cell flow that we described by
the hydrodynamic approach and enters the
laser intersection area of ​​the
cells that are being detected.  shows how the red ray
cells intersect so that they
scatter the laser at different angles
they actually scatter light 360
degrees but we are only interested in certain
angles of light scattering and this
provides information about cell size
its internal structure
granularity and  including the morphology of
the surface the optical signals
generated by the cells are detected and
converted into electrical impulses which are
then stored and analyzed by the
computer system after analysis
once the final event is recorded
these data are evaluated by an
algorithm and all the
Event light scattering angles are
classified by their characteristics.  Common characteristics
if abnormal cells are
present alerts are generated from those
populations and
additional monitoring is obviously required going back to
manual differential
since there are usually more than two
different scatter detectors each
detection signal can be
plotted as dots on a
scatterplot as seen on the
right side the points are plotted at a point
determined by the intersection of the
information of the designated channel on the
x-axis and the y-axis for example the cell
that falls into channel 50 on the x-axis and
channel 50  on the y-axis is located at the
point of intersection of the two
channels thus the
scatter information can be plotted in various
combinations to produce
different information about the sample it
is possible to have several
scatterplots to review for
abnormal events if the
cell concentration is too high or
current rates are not optimized
may  there may be a detection of doublets or
a longer irregular signal that could
represent two cells in
close proximity very similar to what we saw in the
impedance when it happened at the same time
so it is important that both the
injection and dilution rates
are optimized and there  This is when
the designs of the new systems are established again.
I would like to address now how contemporary
hematology analyzers
use various
technologies and methods to determine the
differential of five parts or greater and in
an automated way, so we are going to
consider two primary approaches:
first we will call it a type of
multichannel system a multichannel approach makes
use of two or more discrete detection systems
to quantify the
reportable white blood cell differential so we are actually
doing two separate illusions and
analyzing them in separate areas of the
system for example neutrophils
eosinophils monocytes and l  lymphocytes
may be determined and reported
from one method or technology and
basophils and nucleated erythrocytes may be
reported by a second method
technology and in turn the
leukocyte count perhaps by a third method or
technology
this approach uses the
detection strength of one technology to  overcome
the limitation of other technology
ultimately we are trying to
improve the overall detection rate and
apply proper alerts to ensure
accurate result the second
approach I will talk about is the so-called
single channel system which makes use of
discrete detection systems  that
quantify the
reportable WBC differential in the
single channel approach only one illusion
provides all the
reportable results and the detection system
can use multiple angles
of light scattering and even
additional WBC containments
perhaps to improve the
detection sensitivity and mi  minimize the potential of the
interfering substance
this is an example of a contemporary
multi channel analyzer detection system you will
not recognize any
of the manufacturers in this approach but
I think most of you who may
have this type of technology will
recognize it
in this case the  upper
left histogram indicates that the white
blood cell count was determined by
impedance measurement
lower left scatterplot uses
a one-angle light scattering range
to identify neutrophils
lymphocytes monocytes eosinophils and
basophils lower left
scatterplot  lower right uses
opacity or radiofrequency and volume
to complementary identify
basophils that despite being seen in
the scatterplot on the left
are additionally verified with the
scatterplot on the right and
additional combinations such as the
scatterplot on the top right.
right uses int  light scatter interval
and light loss suggesting size
to differentiate nucleated erythrocytes
from white blood cells thus resolving
leukocyte count the
5 part differential and nucleated erythrocytes
so in this case you actually see
discrete nucleated cells
additional combinations of
light scattering impedance or radio frequency
provide additional information for
the detection of interfering substances
and of course alerts for
potentially abnormal cell types
this is example number 2 also of
a contemporary multichannel analyzer
this system uses a
chemical site staining method for the enzyme
peroxidase which  found in the
granules of some leukocytes the
photo seen at the top shows
two peroxidase-negative cells at
the top of the image along with
two different but
peroxidase-positive cells at different
concentration levels at the bottom  r The
lower left scatterplot
shows the peroxidase arrest activity
of the white blood cells on the
x axis and the relative cell size on the
y axis managing to identify neutrophils
lymphocytes monocytes eosinophils and a
population that is not really classified
which is a large group of cells
negative for peroxidase together with these
data the total leukocyte count is also obtained
in a secondary way
therefore this dilution provides a lot of
information
the lower right scatter plot
indicates the nuclear complexity
as light scattering on the x-axis and the
cell size on the x-axis  In order to
identify the basophils, in addition to the
primary leukocyte count, as well as
additional information for the detection
of interferences and alerts, in this case
, chemical situ was also used, although in
reality we are not having the cells
but doing selective lysis for what we
could call cytochemical effects.
basophils are located  atop
the other light scattering events
because they are intact with the
cell membrane and the lower groups
are representative
of leukocyte nuclei only and are
evaluated based on the respective cell chromatin density
and there is one example a number  three a
contemporary multi-channel analyzer detection
system this system uses a
fluorine or chromium detection method to
obtain fluorescent labeling of
nucleic acids proteins and
cytoplasmic organelles of white blood cells
made analysis at two angles
of light scattering the
scatter plot  left as you
see indicates fluorescence activity
on the y-axis and a
light scattering angle on the x-axis to
identify the combination of
neutrophils and basophils lymphocytes
monocytes eosinophils
immature granulocytes along with information on
nucleated erythrocytes and abnormal cells
the scatterplot  on the right
indicates a second angle
of light scattering on the y-axis and cellular fluorescence
on the x-axis to further identify
nucleated red
blood cell basophils and white blood cell count along
with additional information for
interference detection and alerting
we will now review a single
channel system  remember the single
channel approach makes use of a
discrete detection system that performs the
reportable white blood cell count
and its differential a dilution is used
to provide all
reportable results and white
blood cell counts which will include neutrophils
immature granulocytes eosinophils
basophils lymphocytes monocytes
nucleated red blood cells and
additional information for
interference detection and alerts of
abnormal cells when present
since we touched on fluorescence detection
in the multichannel example
this is an example
of a single channel fluorescent flow cytometry technology
that measures and analyzes
simultaneously multiple
physical characteristics of individual cells
as they flow in a
stream of fluid through a beam
of light in this case a laser
the properties of measured cellular events
include multiple angles
of light scattering as i mentioned not just
two but multiple  that help
determine the size of the cell the
granularity the internal complexity the
lobular and that the intensity of the
fluorescence of the attention of the
nucleic acids in the
nucleated cells these characteristics are
determined using an
electronic optical conversion system that
records how the cell  scatters incident light
and fluoresces let's take a
look at the upper left image at
low resolution this is how it is visualized
in stained nucleated cells
the upper right image is a
high resolution image of categorization
of positive fluorescent nucleic cell events
and can be  see
clearly what is  very similar to when
we do a microscopic evaluation of
a wright containment smear in this
case we are obviously seeing a
fluorescence color the lower
left image and the lower right image
are scatterplots combining
light scattering and
fluorescence detection  by identifying the
cells that relate to the center box
so from this single illusion
we can fully manifest that there are
six parts actually seven if
we include the nucleated erythrocytes this
animation demonstrates the processing
of nucleated cells using
multi-angle scattering of laser light  in
a single channel in conjunction with the
fluorescence emitted by the
stained cells during this process the
diluted cells are rapidly injected
through the optical flow cell of
the analyzer discussed
above in
addition the depolarized light and fluorescence data are accumulated
red
up to 20,000  Events As
the optical and fluorescence data from
the classified cells pass through, they
accumulate into a list that records the
5 pieces of optical and
fluorescence data that we will use to
classify these cells. These
broadly span cell size,
complexity, vulgarity.  the
granularity and staining of the dna
once the data of 20,000
events is collected the software algorithms
begin to classify the
cellular events the nucleated red blood cells
are the first to be classified with
this approach you can see how to
highlight the
fluorescent intensity characteristics of the  events
that are in the DNA axis that have
particularly low values ​​and that will
later be classified as
nucleated erythrocytes,
the leukocytes are subsequently separated into mononuclear
and polymorphonuclear cells using
90 degree polarizing light scattering
to identify neutrophils
from eosinophils the remainder  s
leukocytes are separated and identified in
lymphocytes monocytes and basophils
using their characteristics of size
and complexity the data and numbers that are
seen in the table are the
optical and fluorescent intensity signals for
each of the events that are
later classified make an
indication in the table  color list once
the data is analyzed and completed the
cellular events are
color coded to make it easy for the operator to
see the cells and then
we have this
three dimensional representation of the data which highlights that
this is truly a multi
angle and multi dimensional analysis completing
the differential of  five parts
well as we have just described thanks
to the methodologies and the applications of
those methods
we have come quite far down the long
road of advancement to be able to solve not
only the exact
leukocyte count but also the
five or six part differential we have certainly
seen  than rates  revision of
manual differentials have
dropped significantly during this period
however we must ask how
laboratories view all the advances
in methodologies and applications to
date is enough information
laboratories are satisfied with this
and I think the answer is always no
no  they are
and the reason for this is to this
day the labor shortage continues to
be a challenge for the lab
especially with the continued increase
in testing believe it or not our
populations are aging and the
cliché the lab still has to do
more with less continues to be
always discussed in senior management
however laboratories continually
report that
manual differential revisions remain one of
the most important criteria
when choosing a new
hematology analyzer and view the time consuming and laborious
manual differential as  the main
impediment to further optimize  Its
much-needed saving of labor The
need for revisions of the
manual differential are based on many reasons This is
a study carried out and published by the
cp in 2006 called the Club props study
which examined a series of laboratories
as can be seen on screen
263  laboratories that did more than
95,000 differentials looking to determine
what really is the reason why we
are doing manual differentials
the need for revisions and
manual differentials are based on
many reasons including lack of
results results with alerts or
alarms and of course interferences the
study reported  the reasons for
performing the manual smear reviews
as a reflex test the
differential reviews the performance assessment
and if new information had been learned
from these reviews it is not
surprising that the white blood cell alert
and or the presence of
immature cell alerts accounted for more than  62
percent of the samples  that
required additional revision since
this study was done almost 12 years ago
the number may have improved but
a considerable number of revisions are still being done today it
is also interesting to note that
manual diff accounted for 60
percent compared to manual scanning
of  40 percent
So it seems that people have
a tendency because improving
technology may reduce the incidence
of scanning but because it
can't resolve abnormal pathologies it
increases the number of
manual differentials compared to just trying
to do  a scan
this is why laboratories
doctors and patients face the
consequences of the results with
alerts that are reported without
smear reviews we know the interferences
associated with white blood cell
count and differential have not been
eliminated despite all  advances
in detection technologies
used by the new generation  tion of
hematology analyzers the need
to visually review alerts
remains a very important step in the
verification and validation of the reportable result
this is a list of
white blood cell interferences that remain
numerous and standard procedures
are designed to capture them
when alerts are in  the instrument indicates a
problem with the sample this post
was made around 2007 but still
today we are struggling to overcome
some of these interferences by
some of the technologies on the market
some of these interferences will never be
resolved as they are pre-
analytical issues that may have  produced
in the collection of the
blood sample or it could be a condition
of the patient such as high lipids or
even with agglomeration of
platelets instrumental methods
research and development are
continually making progress in
minimizing the impact of the
interferences and surprisingly
some of these have been resolved but
many of them still not
the efficiency of alerts in
automated hematology for
white blood cell count and
differential becomes an
important contribution to
increase productivity by accurately lowering
rates  of slide review
in other words when developing
new technologies
many cellular characteristics must be considered to
try to understand and identify
especially immature cell types
as you can see on the left of the
screen the variation of
blast alerts is large there is a high  degree
of shapes and sizes and therefore
a variety of strategies are needed
for our systems to detect
these immature cells
for its part the laboratory must also
establish its own criteria for
response to alerts fact the
international council for the
standardization of hematology  has
published initial guidelines each
laboratory should review and adjust their
protocols based on the
patient population they serve regarding
alert conditions the
reduction of 'false positives' and the
minimization of the number of false
negatives have continued to improve
with system interaction  in its
next generation however
we still have a lot of room for improvement
with improvements in laboratory information systems
many rules can be applied to match
the alerting efficiencies of
automated systems in general
now let's explore some of the
future trends of analysis
Automated Differential
We have talked and discussed about the
various current methodologies and
associated applications mentioned
here but let's take a closer look
at potential developments that
may impact the next generation
of hematology systems
new improved chrome flow will be developed
improvements in reagents will be possible could
a new detection system using
advanced optics or other technologies
help improve hematology analyzers
could be all of that could be possible to
use additional
light scattering ranges or take advantage
of advances in artificial intelligence
with the use  of a
learning algorithm that catalogs
abnormal cell types and remembers their
respective technological fingerprints that
can later teach the
analyzer how to find the
abnormal cell all of this is possible
this is a development that could have
a major impact on further investigation
of abnormal cells  automated systems
there is a study that is often not
talked about but to which we have
drawn our attention was done by the csh or
international council for
standardization in hematology with the
aim of designing a new method to
replace the
current reference methods for differential  of blood cells
bl  ancos that today is totally
dependent on expert micro copyists
when performing the
manual differential of 400 cells as a
statistical limit the csh has indicated the
need for a new
reference method for
differential leukocyte counting the proposed approach is to
investigate a candidate method of
flow cytometry using multiple
monoclonal antibodies
I can remember many years ago perhaps
30 years ago that it was believed that this
would actually be the
WBC differential of the future
unfortunately due to the
prohibitive costs of
monoclonal antibody testing and the use of the
technology limited this to
special tests for the detection and
identification of advanced disease
however if we have a
reference set of methods with
monoclonal antibodies this could be developed and would
provide manufacturers and
research with
true reproducible cell classification and co  Confirmed to improve their
respective technologies and
subsequent developments in
algorithms one of the most
frustrating applications today is when
we try to compare
one observer's hand review of 200 cells with a
second observer or even a
referee and many times when a
pathology is present they don't match that
inhibits our chances of
actually using our
learning algorithms to effectively identify
those cell smears so this
would have a big impact
anyway maybe as I mentioned
earlier we could add
additional light scattering detectors and improve the WBC differential
if a new
reference method using
monoclonal antibodies was available that
could truly be used it could further
explore the
refined characterization of cells in
light scattering using such approaches as
supervised learning technologies will
not be  It is not exactly a
neural network that resolves random information,
but rather a
learning technology supervised by a truly expert human.
This would make it possible to establish a
true reference database and then
train a learning algorithm
through a network of information and bits.
deira to understand exactly how
this is going to specifically identify the
abnormal cell type
without that actual database it becomes
very difficult to get beyond where
we are right now using some
of the advances in optical light scattering
and or other methods
and so  of course i think we
are all getting used to the fact that
digital morphology becomes part
of our automated experience for
white blood cell differential
advancements in digital morphology from
cell identifier to
reportable diagnosis could one day
be a reality
as we know today  nowadays many of
us use some ti  type of
digital morphology to help solve and make
the differential within the
expected reporting time therefore the
cell identifier and the technologist
will be called to see and review these
cells that the digital morphology
system has identified let's keep in
mind that at this time  according
to moore's law which isn't really a law it
basically says
cpu processing power doubles every
two to two and a half years
high resolution digital morphology
currently contains lots of big deira and
needs better
processing power  therefore it could be
possible that improvements in
processing speed using
artificial intelligence and advanced
machine learning algorithms could one day
provide the human with machine
compatible images of
white blood cells in such numbers that the
cell identifier could actually be set
to solve  the
laboratory review is therefore  possible
my belief at this point is that this
has to be one of the major
trends in advances in
reportable automated differential
in summary advances in
white blood cell counting and
automated differential testing have
evolved over the past 60 years
to the point where
While normal white blood cell counts and
normal differentials are now
largely reported without even an
intervention, average revision rates
can be as high as 50
percent at large
cancer hospitals or perhaps just under 10 percent
at some hospitals  with
less complex patient populations however there are
still significant numbers
of manual differentials
needing lab review
therefore advances in methodologies
and increasing speed of
processors may further improve
our automation to the point
where only  a few revisions will be necessary
ones manuals we
appreciate the presentation of doctor
donald reid now we will start the
live question and answer round
about this virtual seminar
to answer your questions we are
joined by raúl jiménez who is a
diagnostic voice support specialist in the usa but will be able to
answer them in spanish if you have any
question you would like to ask please
submit now simply click on
the ask a question link which is
located on the far left of the
screen we will answer as many
questions as time allows
so let's start from this opinion the
question is
considering the  limitations to
quantify the differential of the carcit
ary is there still some place for
impedance technology in the
current laboratory
hello cristian hello everyone
the answer is yes
and it is based on the fact that we have a
wide range of laboratories ranging from
the smallest  to
reference or highly specialized laboratories
equipment with impedance technology is
still suitable for laboratories with
financial constraints or with a
considerable percentage of normal patients
the sector or the next question
because it is the processing speed
of current hematology analyzers
has not increased
considerably
appears to be limited only around
100 programs  per hour
what do you do cristian in terms of
engineering and design it is possible to have
faster analyzers that is to say with
greater processing speed
however these instruments could
potentially be out of reach
of laboratories that do not have such a high volume
of samples in the thousands
of samples  per day with the speed of
the current hematology
analyzers it is perfectly possible to meet
all the needs of the market, and
if the option of being scalable is offered, it is
thus adding multiples of multiple
modules and we also have the fact that the
so-called bottleneck  Or the part that
could potentially delay the
delivery of results in hematology
is microscopy and not so much the
perfect analysis. Do
you anticipate that the theological theme analysis will
have a transition to a
rapid or spot test that, like other
laboratory tests,
already exist currently in the  market
devices for rapid tests or
points than
for some hematology parameters
such as hemoglobin and
hematocrit and some others,
however the limitations that impact
the latest generation hematology analyzers,
the latest in
laboratories, would be even greater for
small devices with
simple detection detection technologies it
is my opinion that for
hematology it will continue to be available
only with basic parameters but
not to differentiate
perfect leukocytes here we have a question
that comes from Colombia you already
have this combination maps and
fluorescence
yes
the technology of ma  ps
with fluorescence has been available and
obviously it has been
refined first with demonstrating the
presentation with the cell model in 4000
then a demo of what it is to be a
fae dance and it has been further
refined with
the new equipment to the limit h
perfect because not  digital optical detection technology has been fully integrated
into the
hematology
and cristian analyzers as mentioned
in the presentation today with the
available technologies that were
discussed it is possible to report a large
percentage of the results
intervention of a laboratory
technician or technologist  and this in a
fast and reliable way
one of the current militants of the
image visited by
digital imaging technology is the speed or
the lack of speed with which
it can be carried out so if
we take this into account it is better  apply
this technology to the samples that
really need it, not to all of them,
that is, to take it  as a tool to
help and facilitate the
morphological review and microscopy that this
entails as a complement to
current technologies
what are the new lightning rods
available for hematology and why
are they important
end over the years there have been
various
so-called new pathological parameters offered
by the various  manufacturers such
as
for the phytochemical methodology explain
the presentation there is the outlook which
means large einstein
to which some
potential clinical advantages are attributed according
to certain studies but with many
limitations and this example
as well as other parameters have not been
universally accepted  In the area of
hematology, the laboratories or even have
not received any approval
by any regulatory body, so
to answer this question I
will limit myself to parameters
that are currently correct and have
been approved, and even with the
different technologies,
an example.  what comes to mind is the
mean reticulum hemoglobin concentration
quote as it can be very useful
for diagnosis and monet or
anemia monitoring for iron efficiency
the next could be the percentage of
regulated platelets or percentage of
immature platelets  that is
currently available and reportable that can be
useful for monitoring
political mega heat activity and also the other
parameter that is available with the
different technologies is the percentage
of large immature milestones
how good is the quantification of grade
mature grains call it police ice  or
very interesting pere peyró raúl medicines how
samples and techniques would be processed in this technology
well there are different ways to approach
this type of sample and obviously there are
some guidelines for
laboratories and each laboratory
ultimately is responsible for
determining how it proceeds with  this type of
samples but currently
with the  With current technologies, it is possible
that the instrument gives us some alarm
for this type of sample, some
alarms related to hemoglobin
because when we have high,
highly elite mimic samples, one of the
parameters that can be
falsely quantified is
hemoglobin, so with new
technologies we can or  Instruments
are able to tell us when the
hemoglobin reading can be
affected
by the item, and also with this,
we have that once the instrument
gives us this notification, the laboratory
has to follow its procedures on
how to wait for this type of sample.
Perfect,
what is it?  the objective percentage of
division of fortis to which
an emergency and routine laboratory should aim
you continue cristian this question is
complicated in terms of giving a
concrete answer because the number of process the
percentage of smears depends highly on
one of clear the type of patient is the
type of samples
two of the criteria of  review of the
same laboratory that is to say that the
laboratory that wants to review what
alarms or alerts wants to review what
low values ​​they want to review
and all these review rules are the
responsibility of the laboratory and good
to the management or supervision of the
laboratory and it also has to do with
the type  of technology
in terms of the instrumentation that is
used, the objective of the technologies
is to reduce the number of false
alarms and obviously eliminate false
positive alarms and eliminate false
negatives, but as I mentioned before, the
percentage that you should have,
well, it varies and  It will be very closely
related to the review rules that
the laboratory
determines and well, depending on how I
said it about these rules, because in a
laboratory there may be, and
also having the type of samples, there may be
review percentages of 78 in
some cases.  10 to 15% but hey
these are obviously vague figures and as
I said before it goes  to depend a lot on
technological factors rules and the type
of samples
3rd out thank you very much for answering these questions
would you have any
final comments to the restaurant and
yes thanks to cristian for the questions
thank you all for your questions
obviously there are some partners that we
are not going to  have time to respond I am going
to read them and with great pleasure respond to
all of them by email
perfect thanks to the danish from the umh for
being with us and obviously
thank you very much changed everything for your presentation
it would also be thankful to the eu and
the rest of the sponsor  turn nights
with subscribe is from inah saw virtual the
newspaper before we left they would record
thanks to all the audience for
joining us today and for their important
questions those that we should be
able to answer will be sent during
the period during the period of the
end I will address them later
and the training olympics through
contact 15 on campus porci  Onated at
the time of registration
this webinar will be viewable on
demand for the next six months
the grotto will notify you by
email when it is available
for playback we encourage you to share
this message with your colleagues who might
have missed the live event on  today
thank you very much and until next time good
bye